[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter laville
biden claims victory but what about
those who voted for trump
will they say now not my president and
is europe facing another wave of
terrorism
is neoliberal ideology showing signs of
[Music]
exhaustion
to discuss these issues and more i'm
joined by my guest glenn diesen in oslo
he's an associate professor at the
university
of southeastern norway as well as author
of the upcoming book
russian conservativism and here in
moscow we have excited
moreau he is the founder of the center
of political strategic analysis
strat poll all right gentlemen crosstalk
roles in effect that means you can jump
in anytime you want and i always
appreciate it
okay let's go to glennon oslo uh glenn
what's your major takeaway from this
election here
um when joe biden has been declared
president-elect though
he shouldn't be technically because the
electors have not uh sat down
and voted uh for the electoral college
however we first
for shorthand will say president-elect
the for me the real
focus is what happened uh with the rest
of the election there was no blue wave
um it looks like uh as we speak now uh
the senate will remain
in republican hands thus more gridlock
which may not be a bad idea because if
they had won
uh the the senate uh we could have seen
a number of things that
a lot of conservatives would be against
so um
trump trump's days are numbered in the
white house that it would appear
but even without trump i
now i say there is trumpism and the
media is
not recognizing it and i think that's a
huge mistake go ahead glenn
no i i agree the landslide victory or
the
blue wave they refer to never
materialized
and i think the reason why they expect
it as well
was the notion that the election of
trump in 2016
had been a mistake and this was very
problematic because i don't think they
ever came to terms with why they lost
2016.
instead they spent the last four years
uh undermining the legitimacy
of that election by saying that trump
was merely
a president who came to power by with
the support of the kremlin
and through fake news so because they
never really
took out a clear survey of why
this happened they never really
addressed it and which is why they
thought that this was merely a mistake
and
and i think this this will have firmer
ramifications
now further because uh as they see they
need to
come to terms with uh why people still
voted for trump
uh this time why didn't they have a blue
wave and again this whole idea
that the country would again go back to
normal and unify
it was again based on the idea that
trump was a mistake and
people would reject him but again he
turned out to have started an entirely
new movement and even if he's gone
someone will pick it up there and they
will continue a same a lot of the same
policies and i guess the main problem is
there's no
i don't see any possibility for
unification
or bringing the country together because
again
the the main concern or problem people
have with trump now is he saying that
the election has been stolen from him
and a large part of his uh electorate
will agree with this and
you you can i kind of understand why the
media has
you know far from being been fair to him
uh the tech giants have
actively gone out and censored him and
none of the media kept really biden
at any accountability and also
by a lot of the republicans now
more than 70 million people voted for
trump will ask well
why should we recognize the legitimacy
of biden for the past
four years the democrats did not
recognize the legitimacy of trump
even last week sorry this week already
you had
hillary clinton come out and still
saying now four years in a row that
the election was stolen from her so this
failure to recognize electoral defeat
it is it did not start with trump
and uh so i think they have a lot to do
in order to bring in these divisions and
i'll just like
make one final point they do recognize
that the country is divided because
you have you know now um at least eight
million more people voting for trump
this time
so how can you explain this and even uh
blacks and latinos
all these demographics voting in greater
numbers for trump and how are you going
to explain it i mean
you have you know from biden saying that
you know if you're black you ain't black
if you're not voting for me or
was it al sharpton arguing that all the
cubans aren't really hispanics they're
more whites which is a negative thing
not given that they voted for trump
and uh again michelle obama
came out and said listen we really we're
in dire need to unify our country we
have to reach out to trump voters
because we have to come recognize that
70 of these people
voted to preserve hate lies chaos and
division
i mean how how can you how is this the
opening statement
to unify a country if you say that
unification is between
us good americans have to unify with bad
americans it's just
the premise refusing to recognize
the position of the other side is just
such a horrible point of departure
if you recognize you do have to come
together you know exactly
that's absolutely right because even in
victory
uh we have the people surrounding biden
and michelle
obama being mentioned here continue to
hold
half the electorate in contempt okay we
they that's why there's you have this
this um um
uh talk about essentially re-educating a
trump voter i mean
the lack of recognition that these
people have agency they have
their own values they have their own
interests here there's not a recognition
of that and
on top of it why should republican
republicans uh treat
uh biden any differently than the way
the democrats treated donald trump
go ahead exactly yes exactly in my
opinion it will be more difficult from
joe biden than it was for donald trump
because
uh the idea that the election was
stalled is quite uh an evidence now
and um you know actually in my opinion
it's uh
the end of the moral predominance
of the liberal not only in the united
states but
actually in the world and you know i can
compare that with what happened
in uh in france with the yellow jackets
because
macron repressed this movement
by using uh something like a bloodshed
but he continued uh continues lecturing
the rest of the planet about uh uh for
instance location co in belarus
so what will happen when joe biden if
he's elected
how will will really criticize
for instance i don't know belarus or
ukraine or any african country
as long as i in my opinion there is no
evidences that there is a massive fraud
in the united states so
it's a complete loss of moral
predominance of the west and
especially of the us liberals
yeah exactly you know the glenn the it
seems to me that the left has
has uh forgotten what democracy is all
about
because for them democracy is the
pursuit
is to pursue an ideology it is not to
look for representation they've moved
away from representation
what they want is they want to use the
electoral process
it to um enforce and i use that word
specifically enforce their ideology on
the people
that dissent from it and that and that's
a form of authoritarianism
so democracy is it has no value to them
it's a vehicle that's what it is
actually okay democracy in the united
states
it's when the democrats win the election
well you're right well the democrat
democracy is a system where the the
process is more important than the
outcome
and um and again in in this case you can
actually see that unification of the
united states
would to a large extent rely on the
democratic process so for example now
the dispute is whether or not there were
election irregularities
now the united states has democratic
mechanisms in place for this that is
uh if there are reasons to believe that
there are irregularities then these are
assessed and looked into and it's even
proven to be the case or not to be the
case
however what you see now is probably the
uh
the democrats well you know they've
already decided that there are no
irregularities this is fake news so if
there are regularities will they really
accept that this existed
and on the other side of the coin with
the with the republicans
if there shows that no actually it
wasn't any major uh irregularities at
least not enough to swing the election
uh well they still feel that the
election was stolen so
again this commitment that end results
this
reluctance to to accept that the
democratic process should be held
above the the outcome i it's very much
absent and this is very much due to the
idea that
both sides now see that the other one is
not merely a political opposition
seeking a different path for the country
this both sides are seeing the other
side
as attempting to ruin the country and so
again the
the democrats looking at the republicans
they're just
you know you know essentially want to
remake america's a fascist country which
is
based on some strange assumptions and
then you have
the republicans looking at the democrats
now who are arguing that
well i would say more evidence behind it
that they want to uproot a lot of the
institutions because under the premise
that america's is systemically racist
country
you really have to dig up all the roots
to cleanse it of its
horrible history and origin and it's
just
the democratic process essentially rots
away in this
system in this uh this mentality
exactly there's talk of a truth and
reconciliation uh process like there was
in south africa
for people that were in uh trump's orbit
i mean
we have general flynn we have other
people that have been subject to this
um that's quite terrifying it's very it
sounds like the stasi
to me that you know they want to cleanse
the body politic of these impure
thoughts
again this has nothing to do with
democracy it is about the promotion of
an ideology
that is alien to half the country
actually it's a ultra left orchestra
cortez
you just want to make a list like
like the bolshevik during the russian
revolution
and sending people to jail to finish
them
for instance if you gave to the donald
trump's campaign
uh 40 dollars or a hundred dollars you
will be punished you will be
on the list in my opinion it's typically
of the ultra left uh
usual activities not only in the united
states but even in france it's always
the same
and um and the point what was underlined
by donald trump during the campaign
that biden
won't control either left is completely
true
because and secondly in my opinion uh
biden is not able to
manage the country during the next
during the next four years
so the vice president will be the real
president
and she's an ultra lift she will be a
neutral
vice president i think you know
betraying her is a hard leftist
you can make that case but let me go to
glenn right now i see
her as the quintessential status quo
uh candidate uh politician i mean it's
no surprise that when she was picked
the stock market went up because they
she's gonna do their bidding just like
obama did um
and and so what i see here and we're
rapidly running out of time here
is that the progressive element of the
democratic party
they're going to remind them that
they're around two
okay and and what we're going to see
here with this quote-unquote victory
is the beginning of a civil war within
the democratic party possibly in the
republican
20 seconds glenn go ahead before we go
to the break i agree i would like to
point out that the democratic party are
not
uh unified uh tr uh biden's entire
election platform must get uh biden out
now get trump out of the office
and remember to wear masks now if this
is your
the main election platform it also
reflects that there was a lot of
divisions within the democratic party i
mean
we're going to go to a break here in
that short break we'll continue our
discussion on some real news stay with
rt
[Music]
welcome back to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter labelle
to remind you we're discussing some real
news
[Music]
okay let's go to exactly exactly let's
talk about what's going on in france and
other parts of europe here when we have
the french president
um declaring uh uh there must be an end
to
muslim is uh islamic separatism
it's very interesting coming from the
quintessential
neoliberal of europe talking about this
i mean i i was really quite shocked um
and what it tells me is that this
neoliberal ideology
doesn't understand what it's doing as a
matter of fact it's tearing the fabric
of societies apart all across europe
and they suddenly say oh this is
terrible it's a
it's quite extraordinary let me read to
you some uh coming from a french
institute of public opinion which you
probably know very well
they last week they said the majority of
muslims
under the age of 25 57 believe
islamic law to be more important than
french law in france an
increase of 10 since 2016. so this has
been going on for a while
but all of a sudden the french president
has an opinion about go ahead
uh you know actually in my opinion it's
again a macron's trick
because uh actually islamism in france
is a part
of a more global problem which is
immigration
for the last 45 years france
without any reasons because we are on a
continuing
economic crisis for for 45 years
we imported millions of immigrants and
because
any kind of ethnical statistics are
prohibited we even don't know
how many they are but they are in our
place and you know
the islamism of course is a problem but
it's a
small part in a more global problem for
instance
the french criminologist
xavier author said that 80 of the crimes
in the region of paris is linked to
migrants population
so and we are talking in france of
places
without any control uh where
no policemen neither firemen
never go inside they're under control
there is a book we
were just published about that about
drug trafficking
we have some small uh medallion cartels
everywhere in france
and in my opinion uh emmanuel macron
wants to
make us believe that we have a religious
war no we have a global immigration
problem
and if we don't have this uh migrant we
don't have any
muslim problem so it's not a religious
problem it's a
it's a massive maybe unsolvable
immigration problem
and you know actually just to to finish
macron
would like to solve this problem how the
left republic fight against the catholic
during the 200
last 230 years so we are they are using
the secularistic
uh security ideology to explain that we
need uh
islam enlighted by uh
that's the point here glenn you know
because you know and let's be very clear
i mean
we're talking about the the increase of
what one one can call
islamic terrorism we're talking about
the beheading of this school teacher
recently
uh a very horrific crime and and this is
what spurred this debate here but glenn
i mean
you know there are those that say this
is a crisis of islam that's an argument
you can make but you can say it's a
crisis of liberalism too
um and and i think it's be because
there's a crisis of liberalism
it doesn't uh understand how it's
destroying
a political culture because if you don't
have respect for your own political
culture why should you expect immigrants
to have respect for it go ahead and i
think that was an important
point that macron made that this is not
only
his initiative he will now not only aim
to counter
islamic terrorism he's also to counter
very fundamentalist ideas which are not
compatible with french culture
and values and this effectively looks
like another step in this
increased repudiation of the functioning
of multiculturalism
now this essentially based on the basic
idea that you need to recognize
that there is one culture set of
cultural norms and values
that the society should be able to
organize around again if
if if there isn't then you can't really
complain if some people put islamic law
over french law
if if you effectively argue that you
have all these
different cultures which you should not
we should stand uh
more or less atomically without without
um
yeah being under the same common
umbrella and interestingly this is
very much what macron is advancing would
be a very conservative argument which
exactly that the human beings are very
much organized
in groups that were very tribal and you
know
the role of a state is to make the state
one
one tribe and the role of their
government is should make sure that
this does not take on a belligerent form
where he becomes xenophobic towards
effectively
other tribes but still form fermenting a
common national identity upon
everyone living within those borders
that you have one set of cultural norms
and values
which they can all embrace now that's a
very
reasonable approach to take but i guess
you you are right i mean this kind of
conservative idea that we do do need to
uniform around
uh yes a certain shared ideas
that this impedes on the idea that the
liberals should
stand all on his own and should not be
constrained by
any any uh what's our so-called
indoctrination of culture
so you do have to have a balance between
the individualism and effectively
recognizing that humans
you know we do rely on the collective we
do organizing tribes to a large extent
and if not you can't liberalism in my
opinion
is struggling now with the idea that
they could dismantle the tribe i think
there's now seeing mainly that
the nation tends to break into smaller
tribes where people associate with
different values and identities which
aren't linked to this
government state anymore or the nation
and i think this is where often a lot of
these
problems begin to emerge and again these
problems
yeah these contentions arise because uh
i wouldn't put the problem in france so
solely at the feet of uh the islamic
islamic faith that doesn't seem really
fair
rather it's dead but your point is
is very well taken and i agree with you
i i i i'm not attacking
islam here at all what i'm attacking is
uh
uh neoliberalism um an ideology here
because what you know you know we're
kind of bouncing off what glenn had to
say here you know
they you know they're having um
liberalism in its attempt to create a a
tribe
that where you have familiarity i would
go further than that i think the
liberalism wants to destroy all tribes
okay no identity and recreated it
from based on uh certain laws and civic
duties and all that
people don't think that way they don't
think that way and this is why this
ideology is
is so uh counterproductive because what
it does is it
you you you start to keep destroying the
uh
a civic body and and then people won't
protect it but then you have a
a group of people that feel disaffected
by that ideology where do they fall they
fall on their religion okay so i mean
it's liberalism's fault here
and i want to make it very clear that
none of us on this program and our
viewers
uh tolerate any kind of uh violence and
terrorism like we've seen
in europe recently and that is it is
completely unacceptable go ahead exactly
you know actually we don't have to
forget that uh
the last 40 years in france was built by
the liberals
a complete different paralysis society
in one side you have the lgbt society we
got as a most of the western country all
the new rides i mean uh
[Music]
weddings for a gay and uh any kind of
freedom they wanted and in another side
on this in the same country
they imported uh maybe 10 million of
people from africa north africa or
black africa who are this population
are quite conservative if i can tell
and so so they built parallelly two
completely different society and
actually
the people coming from africa they hate
what they see
and not only with the islam but even for
the christian
for a black christian uh population
seeing this uh waiting for gay is uh
is unacceptable so uh actually they
themselves created a situation on the
name of that everything is possible that
we can
there is no identity we can rebuild the
the the identity
of the black people from africa there
are people from africa
and uh created such a transgender
people and and give them the right to to
to surrogate
mother and so on and so on so uh the
left
created in france a society that
couldn't work that
it won't work actually and uh we were
talking about uh
if you want to talk about how to solve
this problem i have no idea
actually i have no idea what they did i
mean we heard this argument many years
ago in the united states of demographics
is destiny glenn
um but if that is true here then what
cultural values will
uh pre-dominate i mean you you have to
have an organizing principle for a
functioning society
okay now you can do it through some kind
of civic ideas you can do it through
culture you can do it through a number
of ways here but you have to it has to
be a concerted effort
or and i'll use an american political
term a big tent we can bring in enough
people here but if you have an ideology
that just says
you know do whatever you want to do then
people will do whatever they want to do
and that's not always good
glenn yeah and uh well again i guess
that
example france also applies to the
united states there where it was kind of
assumed that
the democrats said you know we're on the
we are the party of the tolerant
the the republicans are the racist so we
will protect
the the ethnic minorities but then
saying
you know if you are black if you are
hispanic this is your identity that's
what defines you so
you know you might not uh you know your
your individual perspectives on you know
economic prosperity or
you know conservatives none of this
matters and if you don't
if you don't vote for us uh then you're
effectively being yeah again
biden said you're not really black if
you're not voting for me because
you know your your identity groups is
what defines you and you have to act
accordingly so
and um yeah again it becomes very
divisive approach
i just want to add one thing though that
with with macron
his is now take on new uh on islamic
terrorism it does
you can't really split the domestic from
the international
uh to such an extent i mean the french
foreign policy kind of have to
reflect these ambitions he has to fight
terrorism
internally i mean it's often pointed out
that yes the americans support the
margins and bin laden in the 1980s and
afghanistan
but since then they support the influx
of jihadists in
during the bosnian war which still
resides there by the way
in kosovo they converted the terrorist
organization kla removed it from
terrorist list
so they would have a proxy on the ground
in chechnya they've been supporting
terrorism uh in libya nato also allied
itself with terrorists on the ground
and now syria will again be very
relevant because now that biden is
taking
control again he will want to step up
effort in northeastern
syria and effectively any allies on the
ground will do
uh that's uh going against the syrian
government
and the russians so to to what extent
this will come back and fight france
we're out of time that you know the
contradiction is glaring glenn thank you
very much i want to thank my guests
uh here in montgomery oslo and i want to
thank our viewers for watching this
video next time remember crosstalk